here's what would happen if the  spinosaurus never went extinct the  spinosaurus lived about 95 million years  ago bigger than the t-rex they were the  largest predator the nile river has ever  seen but they weren't as threatening on  land because  they were pretty clumsy and not well  adapted to it if the spinosaurus still  lived in the nile today the crocodiles  would be looking for a new home on land  humans would need to be more aware of  their surroundings to protect themselves  from the dinosaurs  egypt's history and social evolution  would have been very different since  ancient egyptian culture relied on the  nile river over the years in true human  form we probably would have started  hunting the spinosaurus for food and  fashion  maybe we'd have hunted them so much that  they'd be on the brink of extinction  would they become a protected species or  would we be happy to see them disappear  so